we've been watching these cartoons for
so many years that we don't even
remember what they looks like at the
beginning no one knew that their show
was going to be so popular and this is
what makes their project so surprising
make sure you watch this video until the
end if you want to know why South Park
was in danger when the team started
working on the pilots if you love
cartoons as much as we do don't forget
to subscribe and please give this video
a big thumbs up today we are showing you
the evolution of your favorite cartoons
The Simpsons can you believe that the
first time we saw The Simpsons was in
April 1987 it premiered as a cartoon on
the Tracey Ullman Show on HBO when the
producer decided that he wanted to
include small animated sketches before
and after the commercial breaks creator
Matt Groening created a dysfunctional
family just for this and named the
characters after his own family members
when Groening submitted the sketches to
the animators he thought that it would
be cleaned up during production but they
just retraced his drawings which
explains where the characters look so
crude the Creator didn't want to see the
conventional cartoon color when an
animator said that they could make the
characters yellow groaning thought that
it was a great idea as whenever someone
is flicking through the channels they'll
see the color yellow and know that they
are watching The Simpsons the characters
changed a lot over the years and how
they became those that we know nowadays
many are new while some of them are gone
like Edna crabapples after the death of
the voice actress marcia wallace the
simpsons is now the longest running
American animated program as the 29th
season started airing in October 2017
unfortunately the show might be coming
to an end according to the showrunner Al
Jean he doesn't know what is going to
happen yet but the 30th season might be
the last one spongebob squarepants the
creator of the series Stephen Hillenburg
has always been fascinated by the sea he
even received a major in marine biology
and a minor in art before joining the
ocean Institute in California one of the
first projects he worked on was the
intertidal zone which inspired many of
the characters from SpongeBob
SquarePants
Hillenburg was later encouraged to
create a series with a similar concept
with Bob the sponge the character always
had a
personality but it's funny to think that
he looks like an actual sea sponge
before he was turned into a kitchen
sponge this show was supposed to be
called sponge boy ahoy but Nickelodeon
found out that this name was already
used for a mop product so they changed
it to SpongeBob SquarePants
this show is so popular that with its
first month on air it overtook Pokemon
as the highest-rated Saturday morning
children's series with almost 2 million
viewers it didn't take too much time
before grown-ups loved watching
Spongebob Squarepants - it boasted the
highest ratings for any children's
series on all television with 15 million
viewers every week including 5 million
adults with 11 seasons more than 200
episodes and two movies
SpongeBob SquarePants became one of the
longest-running series on Nickelodeon
and we hope that it will remain just as
popular for the years to come the
Powerpuff Girls it's in June 1992 that
the popular characters were created when
craig mccracken created a drawing of
three girls on a small sheet of orange
construction paper it was only a
birthday card designed for his brother
but the following years they were the
heroes of the short film whoop-ass - the
whoop-ass girls in a sticky situation
however Cartoon Network said that no one
would like a kids show with the a-word
in it - the whoop-ass girls became the
Powerpuff Girls the can of whoop-ass was
also replaced by chemical X
unfortunately as Dexter's Laboratory was
more popular it took several years
before the Powerpuff Girls had their
chance to shine under the spotlight the
series debuted in November 1998 and was
the highest-rated premiere in cartoon
network's history at the time as both
children and grown-ups loved it and it
always scored the highest rating for an
original series each week for the
network with its friday night primetime
ratings six seasons were made and the
last original episode was aired in March
2005 but the Powerpuff Girls are finally
back to entertain a whole new generation
Cartoon Network announced in 2014 that
our favorite superheroes would be back
in the new series that aired in 2016 we
even met a new character Bliss who is
the Powerpuff Girls long-lost sister we
can never get enough of our favorite
superheroes
Family Guy it's in 1995 that Seth
MacFarlane created Family Guy while
studying animation but it's actually
another of his projects the life of
Larry that was broadcasted on Cartoon
Network in world-premiere toons this was
when Fox hired MacFarlane to create a
new series called Family Guy based on
the characters they gave him $40,000 to
make a two-minute animation and he came
back with a pilot instead this is how
the old Larry became Peter and the dog
Steve became Bryan he even said that the
main difference between the life of
Larry and Family Guy is that the life of
Larry was shown primarily in his dorm
room while the Family Guy pilot was
shown after the Super Bowl after the
pilot Family Guy was given the green
light and their creator had the chance
to work on a whole new series
unfortunately it wasn't performing well
so the show was cancelled but many
people thought that it was so funny that
they wanted to bring it back the show
was now more popular on Cartoon Network
and Fox felt that something was missing
without this animated series this is how
the show was given another chance to
come back on television and after
working so hard to bring Family Guy back
on air the team was also ready to make
it better than ever
Looney Tunes Looney Tunes is the oldest
American series of comedy short films on
our list as it was produced by Warner
Brothers from 1930 to 1969 during the
Golden Age of American animation and no
matter how old you are you probably
already know these funny characters at
the time Warner Brothers wanted to
compete against Walt Disney's most
popular character Mickey Mouse by
developing a series of animated shorts
to promote their music it was so long
ago that the show was only in black and
white at the time it was only after 1943
that we had the chance to see our
favorite characters in color it's hard
to imagine Looney Tunes without our
favorite characters but we only met Bugs
Bunny and Daffy Duck 10 years after the
beginning of Looney Tunes in 1940 then
it's only during the Golden Age of
American cartoons that we got the chance
to meet characters like Tweety Sylvester
the coyote and the roadrunner the
animated series of short films finally
ended in 1969 but that didn't mean that
we wouldn't forget it anytime soon
however the shorts had to be
edited to remove scenes of violence
racial caricatures and questionable
vices many other series and movies
featuring our favorite characters were
later produced to make sure that kids
all around the world will never forget
these memorable characters scooby-doo
there is no wonder why everyone knows
who scooby-doo is the American animated
cartoon franchise produced several
animated series from 1969 to nowadays it
means that your parents have been
watching this cartoon on TV just like
you did and we hope that your kids will
be doing the same thing too it all
started in 1968 when parents started
complaining but they saw too much
violence on television many shows were
canceled because of the pressure from
the parent groups this is why the
hanna-barbera staff started working on a
show that they will later call
scooby-doo where are you
each episode featured Scooby and his
four friends Fred shaggy Daphne and
Velma who traveled in the Mystery
Machine to catch a monster or another
supernatural creature and after so many
years fans still loved to watch the
series with the same concept and the
same ending it was just an elaborate
hoax this show attracted 65 percent of
the Saturday morning audiences who all
wanted to watch Scooby solving new
mysteries and just because we couldn't
get enough of our favorite dog we also
got the chance to see many television
series films television specials
live-action movies video games stage
plays and more projects inspired by
scooby-doo we might have seen the
popular dog and his friends in many
different ways but no matter what he
does kids all around the world will
always recognize this funny character
Fairly OddParents you could have seen
fairly oddparents on another channel
because it was originally pitched to
Cartoon Network unfortunately you never
saw the pilot on this channel because it
was later pitch to Nickelodeon and this
is when people started being interested
in this show at that time fairy
godparents was only a seven-minute
cartoon film that was part of oh yeah
cartoons the design was really different
as the animation in the shorts were not
as smooth and you couldn't see the faces
of Timmy's parents
moreover Cosmo was more intelligent
Wanda who used to be named Venus was not
the smart one and Vicky was less evil
it's all
funny to think that Timmy was supposed
to wear a blue hat but the Creator
batard Minh ran out of blue ink so he
made it pink instead we wouldn't imagine
Fairly OddParents in any other way than
those we later saw in the real TV series
the real show ran from 2001 to 2006 and
was immediately popular as both kids and
grown-ups loved it it even became
Nickelodeon's highest-rated show in
early 2002 and 2003 unfortunately all
good things come to an end and the show
was cancelled in 2006 but it still had a
chance to come back in 2007 and also
inspired fairly odd baby if you could
have one wish which cartoon would you
like to see back on television Teenage
Mutant Ninja Turtles we first saw the
Ninja Turtles in comic books and the
four characters were so popular that
they got the chance to be part of
cartoon series films and video games
the first TMNT cartoon series began in
1987 and quickly became a regular
Saturday morning syndicated series
compared to the comics this show was
much more humoristic and this is why it
made the Ninja Turtles more popular than
ever
moreover they were now wearing different
colored coated masks which made it
easier to identify them compared to the
characters we saw in the comics but we
still think that it doesn't make sense
that they wear masks as there are not a
lot of turtles like them in this world
the series was later expanded to
weekdays with 47 more episodes for the
new season the original animated series
ended in 1996 and was replaced by the
live-action series Ninja Turtles the
next mutation unfortunately it didn't
last long and we had to wait a couple of
years before our favorite characters
came back in Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles from 2003 to 2009 this show was
followed by the third animated series
also named Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
from 2012 to 2017 and Nickelodeon later
announced a new 2d animated series
titled rise of the Teenage Mutant Ninja
Turtles which will debut in 2018 why
can't we just stop canceling this show
and make it last forever instead Pokemon
the franchise began with video games for
the original Gameboy and quickly became
the second best-selling
Oh game franchise behind Nintendo's
Mario these Pocket Monsters were so
popular that we quickly had the chance
to see them in trading card games toys
animated television shows movies and
comic books fans who watched this new
anime on television were always
surprised as the adventures are
different from the Canon that most of
the Pokemon games follow the original
series was titled Pocket Monsters or
pokemon in western countries and began
with Ash's first day as a pokemon
trainer with his first Pokemon Pikachu
the first series was based on the
storyline of the original games while
the next series was based on the second
generation of games and so on until the
sixth generation of games we also had
the chance to see twenty movies based on
the popular franchise and also many
specials spin-offs and variety shows the
latest series Sun and Moon started in
2016 for the season 20 of Pokemon with
almost 1,000 episodes many generations
of kids all around the world fell in
love with these Pocket Monsters the
franchise knows exactly what to do to
stay more popular than ever over the
years with games like Pokemon go so we
are pretty sure that nothing will be
able to stop these famous Pocket
Monsters Pokemon is the very best like
no one ever was South Park Parker and
stone met in film class and quickly
found out that they both loved Monty
Python this is what inspired them to
create an animated short entitled the
spirit of Christmas they created it by
animating construction paper cutouts
with stop-motion which explains the look
of the animated series that we know
nowadays they also included prototypes
of the main characters that we would
later meet in South Park as their videos
became more and more popular they
started thinking about developing it
into a television series unfortunately
Fox was not interested in the series and
this is why they decided to turn to
Comedy Central instead to make sure that
it would never be a kids show
then they started working on the pilot
but South Park was already in danger at
the time as the audience didn't like the
show and many women hated it we have to
admit that we understand why as some
jokes can be really inappropriate it's
over the internet that South Park gains
more popularity to Comedy Central
decided to
give them a chance with a run of six
episodes they never regretted this
decision as there are now 21 seasons and
more than 250 episodes of South Park
what is your favorite animated series on
this list don't be shy to answer in the
comments section down below we'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for
the evolution of your favorite cartoons
for more stories like this make sure you
watch 10 cartoon secrets finally
revealed thanks for watching and see you
next time
[Music]